we have a voicemail number. That number is two
one nine two David P. I got a voicemail from our
old friend Troy York. As many of you know, Troy
York calls in with different characters. He has
a Hispanic character named, as he pronounces it,
Ramon Ramos. He has a black character named Jamal
Jenkins. I mean, all of this is just horrible. And
sometimes he doesn't say his name. But Troy York
called in and admonished me, why am I not calling
out the pro Biden events and rallies and parades
as being a problem from the standpoint of
coronavirus? Here is what Troy York had to say.
Hi, David. Hey. I was just wondering if you're
going to say anything Monday about the super
spreader events that are occurring today
with with these rallies and celebrations. And
I am so disgusted by how many how large this crowd
is. It's totally disgusting. These young people,
they're out without masks. I see very few
masks and they are spreading coronavirus.
And I just wonder if you're going to be
nonpartisan and unbiased and call them out.
I mean, these crowds are utterly ridiculous
and essentially what is actually amusing by
looking at these people in Brooklyn,
they are essentially celebrating.
Joe Biden, who is not a leftist, and Kamala
Harris, who is a policewoman, as Jimmy DA
would say, and essentially you're going to
have more and more with Joe Biden, he's OK.
You're not. But let's focus on the coronavirus
stuff. I didn't even wait till Monday during
my stream on Saturday, I called out and said,
we have to be very careful about these events
because these are events that as we see a third
spike happening. Remember, Europe's on Spike, too.
We're on Spike three. Donald Trump got us an extra
spike by failing to deal with the virus. I express
concern now. Most of the rallies I saw, everybody
was wearing a mask. So I don't know what video
troikas referring to. And in fact, Fox News called
out CNN for not mentioning the fact that these
rallies present a coronavirus risk. And CNN had
called it out. Jake Tapper had called it out and
so had others. So please, here's what I'm asking
you criticize me for things I've actually said or
things I've actually not said. If the criticism
is for the absence of a commentary, because when
you criticize me for something I did actually talk
about, it falls very flaccid. It falls very, very
flat. We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the apparent truce between AOC
and centrist Democrats evaporating. We will talk
about Governor Ron DeSantis in Florida wanting
to expand Stand Your Ground laws. And we will
talk about the Utah governor issuing a statewide
Marzook mandate amidst the virus surge.
All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Grab a membership at Join Pakman
Dotcom to instantly access the bonus show.